the Joe Rogan experience that it's
interesting that there's different you
were different ones for different events
yeah so the pulling for the truck tire
one you use a hiking one so you're
saying so this will be my first time
using that typically we use rock
climbing shoes because real grip super
grippy and especially like we're pulling
on asphalt usually mm-hmm so that'll dig
into the asphalt these ones that I have
from innovate now they're they they're
like anti slip and they have gripping
treads on them so I'm gonna be using
them for an event called the wheel of
pain coming up at the Arnold strongman
classic which is based off of the movie
Conan the Barbarian oh where you see him
pushing that big ball yeah I'm gonna
implement so they actually rogue
recreated that implement no for the
Arnold yeah if you could pull a picture
of that it is the most badass thing ever
Arnold so this is like a three hundred
thousand dollar piece they even did it
with the carving in jet dude that's so
cool wild so you literally just have to
push it so those big wheels are filled
with sand because they don't want to
make it too easy for us Wow and you just
have to push it in a circle as far as
you can in 75 seconds oh wow
that's everybody looks [ __ ] exhausted
how 60 seconds even better it just hurts
man Oh looks like it just is it's like I
mean you know like I mean you work out
so it's like imagine even doing
something like as simple as like rowing
on an ERG for 60 seconds just all-out
non-stop guys pushing on his head
yeah so this last year was the first
year they did this event and they
changed the rules this year where you
have to keep your hands on the implement
like that like Brian's doing right there
cuz someone was just using their head
yeah so they don't want anybody to do
that anymore it seems like that would
crush all your vertebra yeah so you have
to keep your hands on the implement at
all times and push like that what a dope
design though I mean it really does yeah
that's [ __ ] it's so cool it's all
carved out of wood - who built that
[ __ ] thing rogue they just hired
artists to car that rogue enemies get
this room has everybody they I mean any
anything anything you could think of
there
they have people to make it there
[ __ ] echo bike is the greatest cardio
machine thing that I've ever used best
and worse because it hurts the best but
look at this [ __ ] thing with the
snakeheads and everything yeah
what an genius could see it rolling back
when he let go and that's because
there's sand in those big wheels so you
have to push it against sand so now they
have to deconstruct this and bring it
back and put it back together again
because it's not like you could [ __ ]
ship it and this is the this is the only
contest they use it for they use one
time he's using his shoulders yeah he's
Russian what do you expect Rosen that is
a crazy thing though yeah that you can
kind of use your shoulders and push with
your hands yeah so this will be the
second time we're doing this event so
they switched it a little bit have to
keep your hands on the implement at all
times and then it's just push until you
can't anymore god damn that's bananas
look at that yeah everybody looks so
tired I mean this is one of those events
were like usually like the medics will
come over like with oxygen afterwards oh
yes it's crazy
bum bum bum yeah and he's got that
Russian brewery on too so he actually he
actually is in the Russian military - is
he really he's like the Russian
equivalent of like green beret so he's
done he does strongman yeah top of that
yeah that's a manly [ __ ] he's
scary
he's the next guy to come on he's super
nice but you know guaranteed so free Rob
that's so free why could not be I don't
even think he's English isn't that good
no it's so bad no but they also I mean
these Eastern Europeans are smart
because they'll play dumb on purpose to
not listen to the rules oh and at random
oh really oh yeah sneaky [ __ ] yeah like
I don't know but they [ __ ] know yeah
how many Russian guys win it cuz you
would think that would be a thing like
Russian do you think of strong people
you think of Russians Eastern Europeans
are always in the mix um but honestly
like dominating across the board lately
he's been us Iceland and that's about it
is it because we have the best steroids
it could be it might have something to
do it yeah yeah what God testing do they
do
yeah there's look I mean they test us do
they they don't tell us what for
oh so nobody gets in trouble no I got
caught from weed what well I mean they
said do you smell cause like well it's
legal in Massachusetts so yes and sir
okay yeah I mean they don't want us like
taking coke or like you know stuff like
that yeah that's what I would worry
about right it's like someone getting on
amphetamines yeah no they do test for
that like they test for like you know
prescription pills yeah yeah I don't
know about that you [ __ ] get really
strong on that [ __ ] uh probably be you
probably rip everything house on Sade
probably break your body yeah you
probably not you wouldn't understand
boundaries you just go I had a buddy of
mine got in a fight he was on PCP and a
dude bit off his finger and he didn't
even realize it now he has a toe that
they took they took his second toe and
curved it so he could still punch so if
you shake his hand his right hand we
shake see he's got the effects of new
meaning to shake a leg
his pointer fingers index finger is
hazard it's curved permanently so he
never he never has like a flat hand like
that and it's his [ __ ] toe that's why
yeah yeah
boxing my old boxing coach Wow shout out
to Joe Lake
hey but um yeah so yeah so like they
don't want to take us like they don't
want us taking like that kind of stuff
right but um man it's pretty much that's
it that makes sense
just cuz it's [ __ ] dangerous to it
dudes it have heart attacks like you
push that thing on me kinda and it is it
is wild
[Applause]